[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les présidents vont et viennent et même le
pouvoir de la fête change mais la
direction politique principale ne change pas
c'est pourquoi dans le grand schéma des choses
je suis super on s'en fiche de savoir qui est à la tête
des États-Unis on le sait  plus ou
moins ce qui va se passer et donc à
cet égard, même si nous le voulions, cela
n'aurait aucun sens pour nous d'interférer
[Applaudissements]
ailier n'importe où sur la carte du monde
et partout vous vous plaindrez certainement
que les responsables américains interfèrent
dans les processus électoraux internes, mais avec
respect, cela ressemble à une justification
à la qui ne ressemble pas à une
justification cela ressemblait à une
déclaration de fait pas de réunions entre l'
ambassadeur kis lyac et quiconque de la
campagne Trump pensez-vous que de
partout dans le monde  des
États-Unis, l'ambassadrice m'a rapporté
chaque jour avec qui elle menait ou de quoi
ils avaient discuté là-bas que nous complétions
des bêtises
comprenez-vous même ce que vous avez demandé
êtes-vous retourné parler avec l'
ambassadeur de ce qu'il y avait dans ces
discussions qu'il a eues avec Jared  Kushner
avec quelqu'un d'autre de la
campagne Trump, c'est tout simplement incroyable,
nous avons tous créé une sensation si vous
regardez à partir de rien, rien de la
sensation que vous avez mise à votre sujet l'a transformé
en une arme de guerre contre le
président actuel, eh bien c'est vous savez  vous êtes
juste vous êtes tellement créatifs là-bas
bon travail vos vies doivent être ennuyeuses